,
tant l'avionneur que
la compagnie aérienne nient
toute foANNE RIGAIL,
directrice générale, Air France
- C'est donc un message
de soutien que je
délivrer aujourd'hui, et pour
le reste nous réserverons
nos interventions au tribunal.
GUILLAUME FAURY, Airbus Airbus s
- J'ai dit ce que j'avais
à dire, j'essaie d'être le plus
sincère possible  possible  post
à la situation, par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé.
sur le banc des prévenus.
Les deux entreprises sont jugées
pour homicides involontaires
l'une des pires catastrophes
onautique européenne.
Le 1er juin 2009, le vol AF447
reliant
s'écrasait en pleine nuit,
quelques heures ap
son décollage. 216
et 12 membres de l'équipage
ont péri; c'est la catastropheme
d'Air France.
Les premiers débris de
l'Airbus 330 ainsi que les corps
ont rapidement été retrouvés,nts
plus tard que l'épave
et les boîtes noires ont été
repêchées à près de 4000 m
de recherches sous-marines.
Elles révéleraient que les
pilotes avaient été désorientés
et qu'ils n'avaient pas purattre
l'appareil, qui allait heurter
Comment expliquer
ont-ils commis des fautes?
Étaient-ils assez formés?
Des questions qui continuent
des victimes.OPHÉLIE TOULLIOU,
proche d'une victime
t enfin
la vérité sur cet accident.
Me SÉBASTIEN BU des des des dess
fam. des vict., vol Rio-Paris
- Pour quelle raison
il s'est abîmé en mer, pour
quelle raison, leurs proches,
les 228 personnes qui
- En sep- En sep- En sep- En se,
le tribunal de grande instance
dans ce dossier, ordonnant
un non-leureureureureureur
d'Air France et d'Airbus.
Les juges estimaietenu de chargs
suffisantes contre les deux
entreprises. Les proches
de victimes ont fait appel
a été renversée en 2021,
laissant place à ce procès.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,